hello everyone Matt here from code Tech
tutorials just going to walk you guys
through some bit set and C plus plus on
how to use bit set and just this is just
the basics stay tuned for part two if
you want to see a little more advanced
stuff so we're just going to go straight
to it and walk through some code I
assume you know how to make a main and
compile it if you watch my channel but
if you're confused uh you know feel free
to watch some intro stuff on the C plus
plus series or something I don't know
you'll figure it out you can always ask
in the comments or join the Discord or
if you really want some one-on-one help
join the patreon
all right well without further Ado let's
get on with it so if you're going to use
bit set if you're in Windows E2 or using
a Windows Windows compiler like you just
needs just bit set if you're on Linux or
Mac OS you're probably using GCC or
something or clang and you might need
one of these includes so uh there you go
now we're going to type to have a few
things just to not type standard all the
time basically uh the C out we're just
going to be log and end line we're going
to use end log of course we're using
string and IO stream string actually
comes in bit Set uh we can take a look
by just pressing F12 or if you want to
go into the header however you want to
you can apparently it doesn't find it
but uh
if you do find it you'll see that they
use string because it's defined in one
of their functions anyway let's continue
so the standard way to use a bit set is
to just type standard bit set and then
however many bits you want as your type
I'm just going to call that 32-bit
basically anytime I type this it's gonna
be uh this so you can probably figure
that out from from that and the same
thing with string I'm just doing this to
avoid typing the standard basically all
all over this following code all right
so first of all let's just uh I guess
run this and walk through it so I'm just
going to go ahead and run it I've
already got it set up
and there are all the results bring it
over to the side bring this here and
hopefully this is visible enough I know
it looks a little messy but we'll get
through this all right so first of all
let's talk about converting decimal
numbers to Binary this is very easy you
just take your decimal number
and you call it with one of these types
put it into one of these types
if you want to see it in whatever
however many bits that's what you put it
in and I've ran this a bunch of times
here I've uh set the number to zero and
uh then set it to show as eight bits and
you can see that here right at the top
integer 0 as a bit binary equivalent all
zeros and then we plus 128 so now number
should be 128 what's that look like as
you would expect in eight bits the very
first bit is set and the rest are zeros
since uh it's 128 in binary all right
and uh let's go up 64 more and show it
and uh you'll see the next slot down is
a one as would be expected by the binary
math and so on and so forth you can see
all the examples this fits them all out
and we do get to something interesting
once we hit 256 okay so we see 255 is
all once an 8-bit and then once we go to
256 it overflows
and these are all zeros so you know it
looks like this except there's one more
digit that you can't see so if we cast
it as a 16 bit
there
then it overflows to something that we
can actually see so you got to be
careful about the sizes eight bit eight
bits is only uh zero through two that's
an integer
as you can see here and that's all we're
going to cover for that that's just
something you can do if you want to get
some visualization basically but uh
that's that's more for demo form yeah
you can look at all the others you want
and compare and check and make sure it's
correct it should be
but let's continue on so the next thing
we do is we make a 32-bit set and we're
just calling it set one and then we're
going to display it and we'll see it is
all zeros that's the default on these if
you don't set them these are all zeros
now we're going to do the any function
any returns true if anything is at least
a one it returns false otherwise and you
can see that that since this is all
zeros any is false and then we're going
to use the none function another
function you can call on your bit sets
and none will return true if
everything's a zero otherwise false and
you can see that that returns true as
none are set that is true and count
counts the number that are set so you
can see here count to zero because
they're all zeros and then you can do a
size minus count
to see how many are zeros the size gets
the size of this thing of course it's
going to be 32 and Count's going to
subtract how many are ones so you can
essentially get how many zeros that way
size minus count and there you can see
that is is 32 zeros as would be expected
all right so let's do some other
examples let's make another set and
initialize it to the integer 21. so what
happens here when you initialize as an
integer if you if you can manage to get
to this header
uh you should be able to even go check
if you want but
once you uh check it out you'll it'll be
pretty clear it just sets it uh just
like these up here
it just sets it to that number in binary
so 21 is of course the famous Blackjack
number uh it's 10 10 1 so we should see
that here on set two and we do there at
the end is 10 10 1 and then we can just
do the other same things we'll do the
any check it's true the none check false
in this case uh three ones on the count
yep and how many zeros 29 looks good
let's go on to set three you can also
use strings with ones and zeros to set
these so just a Constructor they've made
which I think is interesting
um and we can go take a look exactly
what it does it just sets it as you
would expect
I can't imagine actually using this one
in code but who knows you might the
options there you can see the rest of
these checks on set three look good
let's go to an 8-bit set and play around
you can also index into these and it
starts
from the rightmost being zero so if we
set index one it'll be the second from
the right and we can see
uh that should be there and then we can
also set there's a second set here just
to kind of initialize things and change
index four
which will be from the right the fifth
one over because it starts at Zero from
the right so we set that one as well and
we do a little console out the same
checks and you can see there's the 8-Bit
set the any the none and uh the other
checks but we start doing some more
operations here just to play around a
bit uh let's
do a bull representation so you can do a
test and test returns a test on some
index will
return true or false based on that index
you can see we're just doing a loop over
the size and then checking all of them
and you can see we get
this here
now this is starting from the rightmost
so this kind of has it flipped or this
false is here
right and this true is here
so if you try to go from left to right
on both you're going to be confused it's
because uh the way we did this I guess
you know we could flip this around and
start this at the size
let's do that and then minus minus here
and you see where this is going
and we do it while I is greater than
zero
I also want to do it when I is 0. so we
need to make that greater than or equal
to for this to work properly and the way
it's currently set up so let's go ahead
and give this a fresh run
hit F5 here and we should see that
Blu-ray updated
oh we have an exception thrown for out
of place now uh you should know why this
is happening this size needs to be a
minus one because the size is eight but
we can only index from 0 to 7. make
sense okay just a standard of these
arrays so let's run it again and this
time we should get what we expect here
there's the bull representation and we
have now reverse ordered it so that it
goes from left to right from left to
right do that if you want or just know
that you know that's a thing you
probably already know that if you're a
programmer but just thought I'd do a
little fix it on the fly a little I get
a little hacking experience if you will
all right then we just do some more
stuff you can call set set without any
without any index will set everything to
one so set is like set them all like
true to all of them the default here on
set is true you can also set specific
indexes to specific values
you can see we're setting four to zero
and uh we'll see that there there's four
zero and then there's also set without
specifying anything and the default is
one in that case so if we set four to
its default it'll be back to all one so
as we can see here and a few more things
here we will reset
okay the reset function yeah let's the
resets default
is zero and so you can see if we call
reset on position two position two is
zero if we call reset in general it'll
set them all to zero
like so
and uh we can also call Flip there's a
flip operation you can flip one specific
bit by calling this position and you can
flip all the bits by just calling it
generically with no index and you can
see that in operation we flip just two
so it goes from all zeros to position
two being a one and if we flip them all
after that only the two is a zero so
that seems to work as expected all right
stay tuned for part two and we'll do
we'll start getting into some
mathematical operations hope this has
helped your understanding of how a bit
set works
and uh Happy hacking